Jesus what is this now the fourth lilo
and Stitch movie is again crazy well
thankfully Leroy and Stitch is the last
of these films and I say thankfully
because it actually kind of goes out on
a good note and that is to say for what
it is I'm finding out more and more some
of these direct-to-dvd sequel have to be
taken for what they are for example I'm
going to judge something like Lion King
2 which is a direct sequel different
lead I am Tarzan and Jane which is
obviously just supposed to be a pilot
for a TV show and at the beginning of
this one you can very quickly see what
it's supposed to be not a pilot for the
TV show but the ending of the TV show
now keep in mind I didn't watch the
cartoon show but I got the general gist
lilo and Stitch are going around trying
to collect all the other experiments
turn them good and stop the bad aliens
from collecting them and taking over the
universe well that's exactly where this
movie starts off lilo and her friends
are being rewarded by the intergalactic
council they're all given chances to do
what they've always wanted to do whether
it be go back to their evil lab or be
captain of their own spaceship but we
will admit that she's really going to
miss them that doesn't want them to
leave they decide to stay behind but she
realizes she made a force them to make
the wrong choice and does she finally
says goodbye they all go their separate
ways but hamster wheel the villain of
the last kind of sequel and the villain
of the show escapes and makes a clone of
Stitch an evil clone of course which
makes a clone of that clone and a clone
of backbone and soon there's an army of
Leroy's that want to collect all the
experiments that were set free destroy
them all and of course get back to their
evil plans of conquering the universe
much like the movie pilot Stitch this
film focuses again on the aliens which
are once again very funny below is once
again given a smaller role but I feel
they actually do have the emotional
connection there for example I really
like that she becomes friends with
experiment 6 to 5 or as she now needs
improvement I like seeing these to work
off each other I also really liked
seeing hamster we only kept on the
guards to work off each other they're
still really funny and unlike a lot of
the Disney sequels it actually builds up
to a good climax you think it's going to
be another one of those abrupt happy
endings where it's not really that big
of a climax it's just kind of a tiny one
because hey they don't have much of a
budget but no
they without all of the clones of Leroy
and have them battle all of the
experiments I'm pretty sure that we're
in the show and all of them look
different and sound different and have
these unique powers and yeah it's really
creative it's funny it's energized it's
a lot of fun now granted what ends up
saving the day might be a little too
silly I don't know it's lilo and stitch
I get it kids these stuff but the battle
before was so much fun I kind of wish it
would just keep going that direction but
that's nitpicking for what is basically
a series finale to a show it seems like
it wraps up everything pretty damn good
the original voice actors of lilo is
back again I'm not really sure why they
switched them out but that's crazy and
her voice again the humorous scenes are
genuinely humorous and even the
emotional scenes are kind of well done
there's a really nice scene where
everyone is saying goodbye kind of going
their separate ways and then when Lila
has to say goodbye to stitch all you see
is him looking at the ugly duckling book
putting it away and they just can't sit
there in silence that's actually kind of
profound it's simple but it works and
maybe that's the best way to describe it
simple but it works you can tell from
the animation that this isn't going to
be the same cinematic quality of the
first film or lilo in stage 2 where they
put a lot more money into it but
honestly for the budget they had I think
they did a really good job does it have
the emotion of the first film no is it
going to be remembered as much as the
first film stuff but again I don't think
that's what it was meant to be it's
supposed to be a wrap up of lilo and
Stitch yes but for the TV show than the
film and truth be told this is a really
fun send-off I can't act like it's
phenomenal but for what they had to do I
saved pretty nicely accomplished again
it's one of the nice things of being
forced to watch some of these movies I'm
a lilo and stitch fan but I never would
have checked out the sequels or these TV
pilots if I didn't have to do this for a
job but because I have to I'm glad I
checked about well none of them quite
capture the freshness or the emotion of
the first ones they come pretty close
sometimes and they were definitely
entertaining throughout the majority of
whether you enjoy the cinematic side or
the television side it's nice to know
that either way lilo and Stitch go out
on top
you
[Music]